[Music]
yeah not good
the first two games have been
i have been poor what can i say
not throwing for content just
yeah i don't even know what to say
just this b5 is displayable here because
i played this against gary meyer
two years ago in the grand cay classic
with castles instead of instead of
bishop e2
no shirts were harmed in the blundering
of this bishop nice one
the ones i think this one would be easy
direct though
it's been it's been through some hard
times
okay so he wants to go c4 a4
don't need to defend it immediately but
i think it makes sense
on knight d7 c5
generally speaking i should be fine
very harmonious development
e4 maybe
i could go e5 d5 knight g4
okay i'm sorry if the arrows sometimes
go astray
i'm very very new to arrow drawing
i think c5 is reasonable can go d5 but
i'm not particularly
oops worried about but only structures
when these
knights on d2 so i think i'll do that
cp a b queen b5
basics
i mean this one
okay
why again was i not worried about this
one
because his knight and d2 is passive
that's why
okay let's bring the knight maybe the
other way the other knights as well
the bishop is a bit passive so
could be a potential worry
and besides it should be noted that
artemia is an
it's uh
is a maneuvering player so
slow slow play like we have in this game
should
in general suit him pretty well
um let me take and then i'll go a5
activating the bishop
but it feels like i'm
making moves rather than playing chess
at this point
i don't see you don't see the
see a very coherent planning what i'm
doing she's got to get an e5 this name
yeah this is probably kind of pointless
okay
sort of enticing e5 i don't think it's
great for me but i feel like in
i can possibly complicate the play then
you find 97 maybe
and this is a threat
with e6 i take on b2 and then knight c4
with a
discovered attack
okay i have to protect back of course
and my my worry here is that these
uh sorry not the but these pieces are a
little bit out of play
so they are tying down some of these
pieces to the defense of
of uh c4 but they're not doing much else
so i think i might have to bring more
pieces to king side
eventually like knight of six maybe 97
rooksy one i'll go knight of six
quinn c3 let's try and bother him a
little bit
i don't think queen a3 was good i think
he needed to go queen i1
then i would have gone bishop c8 trying
to get
trying to get the bishop to f5 know i
think i'm doing fine
knight b2 there's bishop
f1 okay let's go 97
94 i go 95 attacking c4
93 yeah i think he's losing the
thread a little bit here
alright b2 now c4 is falling
and this just wins things change now
um yeah let's grab it
f6 yeah he's still fighting here but
looks pretty pretty bad
now i'll just try and consolidate knight
f7 looks solid
he does have some strong pieces so it's
not like he's
without any compensation but
i don't think it's nearly oh ricky seven
bishop sorry knight e4 okay let's go
over king g8 then
king j8 he takes takes an f6 queen of
six and then 94.
it's a bit annoying okay
[Music]
takes on f6 i'll take back and try and
play an ending with
the pawn up
it doesn't have to take i didn't
consider that
yeah he's he's a tenacious fella
okay let's go h6
take it king of seven
you know my rook was trapped enough
stick so it didn't actually have to take
immediately
now this should win
why did i believe i had him in check
there
why did i believe why did i believe
queen d4 was czech
that was just amazing
i mean i can't even explain some of
these brain farts i'm having
i think if it trades i win
okay i'll try and trade anyway
that's a good way to try and fight
c2 does it win
no i don't think so okay we'll go here
did i actually blow this
i don't think i did yes i did
oh my god
[Music]
seriously